je crois pas
élections cantonales à marseille un test
en grandeur nature pour les partis
politiques français en vue des élections
présidentielles les premiers résultats
dans ce journal
mal payés mal aimé les enseignants du
second degré manifeste qui réclament une
revalorisation complète de leur
profession hlm une première les
locataires peuvent devenir propriétaires
de leur appartement mais tout le monde
n'est pas d'accord certains estiment que
c'est une trahison de la vocation
sociale de ce type d'habitation une
journée supplémentaire de détention pour
marcel carton
marcel fontaine jean paul kauffmann jean
louis normandin d'antenne 2 et roger
auque les otages français au liban n'ont
toujours pas été libérés
madame monsieur bonsoir l'ouverture de
ce journal nous la consacreront pas ce
soir à une personnalité ni à un
événement marquant mais plutôt un
français moyen anonyme
sauf dans la région lyonnaise où il est
connu pour sa bonne cuisine laissant de
côté les grandes déclarations
d'intention ce restaurateur confronté à
une querelle de voisinage qui aurait pu
tourner au confit raciste a préféré
faire preuve de bonne volonté
d'intelligence sans pour autant négliger
ses intérêts et sa réussite
delphine de la scène restaurateurs dans
la banlieue résidentielle de lyon
l'itinéraire de michel brunet classique
stacher mockus et chez la mère brazier
il succès tout naturellement à son père
tradition oblige qu'elle lui c'est son
fief
l'auberge familiale connue comme une
bonne table mais la municipalité
construit à proximité une centaine de
logements sociaux
les choses se gâtent le c'était le
dominer un petit peu on avait une rue
assez étroite et une terrasse qui domine
est le restaurant
donc on avait quelques fois des jeunes
protégés de projectiles on avait
quelques fois
les altercations des choses pas très
agréable pour les clients que je sortais
plutôt en colère
ici on ne plaisante pas avec la
clientèle
pourtant michel brunet ne déclenchera
pas les hostilités devant ces jeunes qui
se défoulent pour combler des loisirs
qu'ils sonnent creux
il va réagir et embauche temporairement
puis définitivement un certain nombre
d'entre eux chacun travaillé ici et puis
et puis ils ont appris à le connaître
enfin l'alcool est le patron et ça s'est
mieux passé
ça va se passer mieux encore grâce au
foot talon d'achille des jeunes de la
cité qui rêvent de luis fernandez
la vedette du parc des princes venus des
minguettes michel brunet leurs voisins
les connaît bien pour les avoir c'est
travailler tout naturellement il devient
le sponsor numéro un de leur équipe
l'association lyonnaise antoine martel
l'une des meilleures de la région vient
une meilleure relation depuis quelques
années depuis qu'il nous a sponsorisé
ça nous fait plaisir déjà d'être
subventionné sponsorisé par lampard dans
monsieur bonnet et ans puisque un patron
patron d'une auberge qui si importante
s'intéresse à un autre club c'est michel
brunet ne se veut pas philanthrope un
problème existait à sa façon il le règle
en conciliant ses intérêts et en
respectant ceux de ses voisins
il a suffi d'un pad un peu de bonne
volonté de part et d'autre pour que le
calme revienne à caluire la politique
maintenant les sondages permettent vous
le savez en permanence aux partis
politiques d'apprécier leurs positions
respectives dans l'électorat mais les
élections reste tout de même le seul
véritable moyen de savoir exactement ce
que pensent les électeurs
c'est pour cette raison que l'élection
cantonale de marseille aujourd'hui est
considéré par l'ensemble des partis
politiques français comme un test à la
fois au niveau local dans la perspective
des élections municipales à marseille et
au niveau national en vue des élections
présidentielles l'année proche a
marseille nous rejoignons tout de suite
daniel brême en direct daniel pour les
premières estimations résultat a même
mené oui nous avons 19
résultat 19 bureaux de vote sur 21 alors
donc il ne manque que deux le candidat
udf rpr de jean claude gaudin est en
tête avec 36,01 % des voix
il ne semble pas que le plein des voix
rpr udf était défait le candidat
socialiste est en deuxième position avec
28 57% des voix
une légère remontée par rapport aux
législatives
le front national fait 18,20 % il est
donc en légère baisse et une passe pas
la barre nécessaire pour le maintien de
son candidat au deuxième tour enfin le
pc avec 12 points 39% des voix est en
progression et les autres listes
d'extrême droite il y en avait trois
fonds 1,80 pour cent qu'il faut sans
doute ajouter au 18-20 du front national
alors dania je disais tout à l'heure tu
est au niveau local pour la mairie de
marseille test au niveau national
surtout au second tour lorsqu'on verra
les reports de voix du front national
oui alors c'est d'abord effectivement
une mesure pour tous les candidats à la
mairie de marseille qui vont examiner le
résultat les résultats à la loue mais à
cinq mois des présidentielles c'est
également un test pour les reports de
voix entre le front national et la main
j'ai hérité et là ce soir on ne peut
encore rien dire et on ne sait pas
comment ça va se passer
merci d'elle merci daniel et rendez vous
dans nos prochaines éditions notamment
notre dernier journal tout à l'heure
enfin programme merci des appartements
hlm vendus à leurs locataires c'est une
première dans la région parisienne du
moins à joinville le pont
les locataires sont bien sûr ravi
d'acheter à bon prix leur résidence
en revanche certains estiment que cette
vente est une trahison de la vocation
sociale de ce type de construction
l'enquète de jean pellieux josiane pas
tous locataires hlm à joinville va
acheter son propre logement
l opéra avec ses économies pour le tiers
est un crédit pour le reste soit 800
francs par mois de plus que son loyer
pendant six ans il y après trente ans
que je suis locataire hlm et je suis
donc rentré ici
le logement était neuf j'ai fait des
travaux j'ai aménagé ma cuisine c'est
pour ça aussi que ça m'attire est acheté
mon logement
et puis bon bah ça reviendra mes enfants
pour mon cas personnel 68 m² 3 5 me en
plus c'est frais de notaire moi je
trouve que c'est une opération
formidable parce que sinon jamais
j'aurais pu acheter mon appartement
c'est pas possible
le prix 5000 francs le mètre carré
correspond à la moitié du prix du marché
autre avantage un crédit total avec un
prêt spécial as 1% d'intérêt qui couvre
le cinquième de l'achat l'offre d'achat
était fait dans cinq immeubles en voici
un autre
certains locataires refusent faute
d'argent les autres par principe sur les
conseils de la cnl selon cette
association de locataires y lit en effet
400 ménages en attente de hlm à
joinville et aucune construction je peux
admettre qu'il y ait des gens qui aident
comment dirais-je qu'il soit attaché
leur logement mais pourquoi alors qu'ils
ont bénéficié d'un logement social
depuis des décennies pour certains
pourquoi volts il ne plus en faire
bénéficier d'autres
alors que pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
création de nouveaux logements dans la
ville et c'est un pas en avant important
dans la liquidation du logement social
et c'est la loi mais iriki et qui nous
amène cette histoire là pour moi la
priorité c'est de donner
au locataire un logement correct et
d'investir dans les rénovations
comment payer de coûteuses réparations
alors que le fils à 9 millions déficit
la vente des hlm gains 25 millions de
francs devrait fournir la réponse mais
certains refusent on l'a entendu qu'à
cause du désengagement de l'état on
privatise une partie des hlm à
l'étranger le chaud et le froid souffle
sur l'amérique centrale où un plan de
paix visant à mettre un terme à la
guérilla dans plusieurs pays comme le
salvador ou encore le nicaragua se met
en place alors que dans le même temps
des combats reprennent parfois avec
violence
michel mompontet l'aéroport de san
salvador roumaine sa mort un homme de
légende de l'opposition rentre enfin
chez lui depuis sept ans il vivait en
exil au nicaragua sept ans durant
lesquels son mouvement le front
patriotique manuel rodrigues n'aura
cessé de combattre les forces
gouvernementales mais aujourd'hui grâce
au plan de paix d'oscar arias il revient
dans ce qu'il appelle lui-même la cache
du fauve entendez par là le pays où
règne napoléon noir thé en 1980 ses
troupes avaient assassiné lors d'une
vague de répression le propre frère de
samora obligeant celui ci à fuir le
retour de samora au salvador est un
signe d'espoir sans doute mais un signe
bien désuet face à l'extraordinaire
montée de violence de ces derniers jours
la guérilla n'a encore même pas accepter
un principe de cessez le feu
duarte quant à lui continue d'envoyer
jour après jour les troupes pour des
missions qu'il qualifie de préventive au
nicaragua même paradoxe de la violence
et de la paix d'un côté la libération de
ces mille prisonniers politiques
c'est un nouveau et spectaculaire signe
de bonne volonté de la part de daniel
ortega
mais à moins de 200 kilomètres de là les
attaques redouble de violence de la part
de la contra y font 20 morts dans six
enfants le 10 décembre
loin de ces conflits à oslo oscar arias
recevra le prix nobel pour son plan de
paix en amérique centrale
une paix qui malgré la violence semble
n'avoir jamais été aussi accessible
grâce à lui
on l'apprend aujourd'hui de violentes
manifestations ouvrières ont eu lieu
samedi dernier 14 novembre à bras sauf
la deuxième ville de roumanie deux
membres des forces de l'ordre des
miliciens auraient été tués et des
dizaines de manifestants arrêtés
des grèves auraient éclaté dans d'autres
villes du pays pour protester contre la
situation économique très difficile
marquée par de graves pénuries de
denrées alimentaires une augmentation
des cadences de travail également
augmentation confrontés à un manque de
matières premières et de pièces dans les
usines
bien que les informations en provenance
de bucarest soient rares et les images
encore plus le mouvement de protestation
ne semblent pas terminés et demain à
paris manifestation des exilés est prévu
devant l'ambassade de roumanie
il y à 12 ans aujourd'hui mouret le
général franco ces dernières année
l'anniversaire de sa mort à madrid ne
rassemblait plus que quelques
nostalgiques de cette période de
l'histoire espagnole
mais aujourd'hui plusieurs milliers de
personnes et beaucoup de jeunes
notamment participé à une manifestation
interdite qui a dégénéré en
affrontements avec la police
philippe lefait la nostalgie perd ses
militants ils étaient cinq à huit mille
tout à l'heure sur la castellana
l'artère principale de madrid bien moins
que les autres années
leur seul souci ne pas oublier le chaos
dit you more il y a juste 12 ans la
fille de franco il a quelque part dans
la foule à côté d'une délégation
française et de tous les nostalgiques
jeunes jouent vieux du franquisme
la nostalgie est illégal en espagne pour
cette cause là le gouvernement gonzalez
avait interdit en effet cette
manifestation comme en 1986 comme en
enfin la nostalgie qui dégénère et la
police qui charge plusieurs fois une
équipe de la télévision espagnole y perd
son matériel et y gagna tabassage en
règle
l'heure qu'il est on ignore si la
nostalgie a fait des victimes
enfin cet après midi visite éclair de
madame thatcher le premier ministre
britannique a paris elle a rencontré le
premier ministre français monsieur
jacques chirac qui multiplie les
entretiens avec ses partenaires
européens avant le sommet de copenhague
la semaine dernière il était à lisbonne
la justice at-elle le droit de juger du
bien fondé d'une grève c'est la question
posée par le verdict du tribunal de
bobigny et qui a jugé illicite l'arrêt
de travail décidée par les pilotes et
mécaniciens d'air inter qui dans un
premier temps refuse de piloter à 2 et
non plus à 3 les nouveaux appareils
airbus a320
alors pour les syndicats c'est clair
c'est l'exercice du droit de grève qui
est en cause mais pour les juristes
quelle est la réponse nicolas jacobs
piloter un airbus à deux c'est
techniquement possible
faire grève pour conserver trois membres
d'équipage dans la cabine de pilotage et
donc illicite
tel est en substance le jugement rendu
par le tribunal de bobigny les juges ont
choisi de se placer non sur le principe
du droit de grève mais sur la légitimité
de ses motifs et distille vouloir
imposer un troisième homme alors que la
technologie permet le pilotage à deux
est abusif cela mettrait inter en
difficulté réaction immédiate des
syndicats cgt et fo et cfdt
c'est une atteinte grave au droit de
grève et le droit par le droit de grève
mais le droit de revendications heroes
encore auquel on board patate c'est une
pente totalitaire c'est la deuxième fois
en quatre mois que les syndicats de
navigants sont ainsi interdits de grève
dans les deux cas le tribunal s'est
prononcé sur le fond ce que la loi lui
permet il faut bien comprendre la
logique de la cour de cassation à la
matière il n'ya de grève licite que dans
la mesure où il s'agit d'un moyen de
pression en direction du chef
d'entreprise pour qu'ils acceptent
certaines revendications et déborde on
s'installe dans ce schéma il devient
très difficile d'interdire aux juges de
se mettre à la place du chef
d'entreprise pour voir si réellement
apte ou inapte à satisfaire une
revendication alors il ya une logique
mais les risques de dérapages sont
évidents par conséquent il ne faudrait
pas pousser là le
i que jusqu'à l'absurde il faut faire
très attention cette matière les deux
syndicats de navigants vont maintenant
faire appel est posée ainsi à nouveau la
question de l'intervention des juges
dans l'exercice du droit de grève alors
parmi les réactions les syndicats qui
vous l'avez compris cherche une riposte
comme la cgt mais aussi c'est important
l'avis du ministre concerné celui des
transports jacques douffiagues suivi des
autres phrases politiques du week-end
rachid arhab dans le cadre des lois qui
le réglementent et bien l'application de
la loi c'est le rôle du juge
et donc si le juge de bobigny après le
juge de créteil a fait une erreur
d'interprétation de la loi
la cour d'appel la cour de cassation
sont là pour redresser le tir en tant
que de besoin ce n'est sûrement pas une
politique de la fin reste que ce la fait
reviendra certainement très vite sur le
terrain politique mais ce week-end tous
les partis se penchait plutôt sur leur
cohésion interne à gauche chevènement et
poperen marquent leur différence mais
jospin reste confiant avant la
présidentielle le candidat lui surtout
s'il représente quelque chose de plus
large aura à donner ses propres
orientations à faire ses choix à dire
peut-être voilà ce que je prends ce que
je ne prends pas donc pour le moment
nous travaillons pour la formation
politique que nous sommes cohésion de la
droite jacques chirac a mis en garde
hier l'ensemble de la majorité contre
les polémiques stériles
le financement des partis politiques
enfin jacques chaban delmas est pur il
l'a dit mais sans précipitation
oui si depuis tant d'années on discute
de tout ça sans aboutir
c'est parce que c'est très compliqué et
alors prétendants quelques semaines
résoudre des problèmes qu'on n'a pas
résolu pendant tant d'années
ça me paraît un peu léger a fait c'est
très français
on l'a des humeurs tout d'un conte
s'excite on condamne montrant son décide
et on va de l'avant il y arrive quand il
dans le mur
et puis ce soir enfin sur rtl le
ministre de l'intérieur charles pasqua a
déclaré que les menaces de l'ancien
ministre de la défense socialisme
monsieur charles hernu
hier soir dans notre journal affirmait
posséder des dossiers de nature à gêner
un certain nombre de gens et bien
pour monsieur pasqua ces dossiers ne
concerne en rien le gouvernement
mais il porte sur ses propres amis
politiques
voilà un véritable problème de société
en france les enseignants des collèges
et lycées qui s'estiment mal payés mal
aimés et qui ont manifesté cet
après-midi à l'appel de leurs syndicats
comme le snes le syndicat de
l'enseignement supérieur et le sni pour
aborder concrètement le problème est
bien lorraine cusin a rencontré un
couple de professeurs qui a mis ses
feuilles de paye sur la 40 ans
profession enseignants j'enseigne depuis
17 ans les mathématiques et j'ai gagné
8,6 à son front j'ai dix ans
d'ancienneté
je vais à nice sept mille quatre cents
enfants enseigne les maths et je
travaille quatre heures de transport de
chez moi ce métier l'ont choisi par
vocation
un mot qui n'a plus grand sens tout
particulièrement dans les disciplines
scientifiques
les étudiants fort en maths préfèrent se
diriger vers l'entreprise le solaire de
départ qu'il pourrait avoir dans le
privé soit en électronique informatique
ou autre et ce salaire ça correspondait
déjà parce que nous on gagnerait en fin
de carrière c'est à dire à 60 ans mais
le salaire n'est pas la seule cause du
malaise des prof principal facteur de
découragement surtout en collège l'échec
scolaire de certains enfants depuis une
dizaine d'années arrive en collège des
élèves aux profils très différents
la formation des enseignants et des
structures scolaires n'ont pas suivi
quand nous voyons devant nous des élèves
qui sont dyslexiques les élèves qui ont
des problèmes qu'on qualifierait de psy
des élèves qui n'entendent pas on a à
l'intérieur des collèges
aucune structure qui permet d'aider ses
élèves vers les enfants qui ont trois
ans de retard en scène
je ne peux pas en vouloir à
l'instituteur de mai envoyée il ya très
peu d'autres endroits où les mettre
c'est triste et les deux cent mille
professeurs à recruter d'ici l'an 2000
un pari difficile à remporter contre
l'amertume et la morosité ce week end
également la coordination nationale
lycéenne s'est réuni pour mettre au
point sa manifestation de la semaine
prochaine le 26 novembre avec un slogan
de l'argent pour l'éducation et pas pour
le sur arm et puis loin de tout captivé
par leur seule passion de soviétiques
karpov et kasparov viennent de terminer
la 15e partie du championnat du monde
d'échecs à séville en espagne les deux
cas seuls en apparence du moins cas dans
le monde entier d'autres passionnés de
ce jeu suivent la partie en direct sur
minitel laurent soir
allez donc savoir pourquoi le tenant du
titre kasparov souhaitait que le
championnat du monde se déroule à
seattle aux états unis et le challenger
karpov aurait préféré abou dhabi mais la
fédération internationale des échecs a
tranché pour l'espagne séville coût de
l'opération 3 millions 500 mille dollars
pour un match qui dure deux mois et demi
une sorte de corridas mental entre deux
soviétique très différents alain thaly
karpov séléné 36 ans champion du monde
pendant dix ans et en 85 et sept petits
tracasse pas rolf karp oif on me dit ah
si tu en un timide solitaire et méfiant
rien à voir avec garry kasparov
il n'a que 24 ans un joueur surdoué
convient sportif fonceur bon vivant et
moderne
des qualités qui en font le champion du
monde est le favori du public
deux personnalités donc et au centre
trente deux petites pièces de bois sur
un échiquier noir et blanc de style de
jeu aussi en tennis qu'apporterait un
bilan d'air qui joue au fond du court
prudent subtil et calculateur kasparov
s'est plutôt mcenroe qui monte second
fils est un jeu complexe turbulent est
tactique mais ici pas de qu'il ait deux
cerveaux une guerre d'usure et parfois
des nerfs qui craque comme ici au 35e
coup de la 11ème parti à gauche car papa
les blancs il est en bonne position
c'est à lui de jouer bien sûr son fou
est menacé par le fouet adverse mais
karpov pour elle déplacée et bien non et
c'est là l'erreur la gaffe il décide de
protéger son fou avec la tour comme ça
le champion du monde n'en croit pas ses
yeux
incroyable
la partie vient de basculer car il met
son cavalier là et il menace la tour
blanche c'est à karpov de jouer il prend
le fou il prend le fou de kasparov qui
lui prend plus gros la tour de karpov et
kasparov gagne la partie
le champion du monde mène aujourd'hui de
8 points à 7 mais il reste cinq épisodes
semaines à jouer et dans le monde entier
comme à paris ou cercles caïdats on suit
chaque coup à la loupe
ici en direct de séville grâce au
minitel est en ce moment le score est de
8 à 7 en faveur de casse parce c'est un
véritable gang franco espagnole qui
avait mise au point dans les vêtements
de la petite mélodie la fille d'une
chanteuse coréenne et d'un milliardaire
libanais en effet après les arrestations
en espagne à marbella d'autres ont eu
lieu à paris ce week end
parmi les personnes interpellées a nommé
jean pierre sang tout qui pourrait bien
être l'instigateur du rap et dont la
fille fréquentait la petite mélodie
annie espoirs dans ce fourgon aux portes
du tribunal de créteil les cinq
malfaiteurs qui ont organisé depuis
paris le rapt de mélodies antoine et
spin alonso sa femme et son ami il
dirige et raoui et jean-pierre santoul
c'est lui que les policiers présentent
comme le cerveau du gang
il possède une maison à marbella sa
fille mélanie était jusqu'à son départ
de la costa del sol l'été dernier la
meilleure amie de mélodies à séparables
elles s'expriment toutes les deux en
français fréquentent la même école et se
retrouve souvent ici à la ville la
mélodie de la famille n'a qu'à chiant
mais le 9 novembre
mélodie est enlevé à la sortie de
l'école par cinq hommes recrutés par
jean-pierre santoul quatre français et
un espagnol angel garcia on perd dans
son portefeuille rempli de brouillon de
demande de rançon il va mettre les
policiers sur la piste du gang pendant
l'assaut de la police de français
réussissent à s'enfuir
les trois autres ravisseurs sont
maintenant sous les verrous côté
espagnol
ce castrais pendant ce jour mélodies
réapprend à vivre
le père de son ami a été inculpé ce soir
pour terminer en avant première sur
antenne 2 le logo du bicentenaire de la
révolution française que vous verrez
fleurir partout dit
en 1989 le président edgar faure qui est
responsable président du comité
d'organisation de ce bicentenaire avait
chargé plusieurs artistes de travailler
sur le thème de la fraternité c'est le
dessinateur fo l'ont bien connu des
téléspectateurs d'antenne 2 qui a gagné
il avait souvenez-vous conçu le premier
générique de la chaîne des petits
bonhommes qui s'envolait voyons comment
il a dessiné liberté égalité fraternité
la dernière image de folon légère comme
une brise servira de logo aux fêtes du
bicentenaire de la révolution
clin d'oeil c'est sous le regard d'un
mao signés andy warhol qui la trouvaient
l'inspiration
parmi les différentes esquisses proposé
c'est celle ci qui a été retenu trois
oiseaux trois oiseaux parce qu'après
tout bleu blanc rouge ça fait 3 et qui
vole la com des des frères parce que la
fraternité ça existe que c'est aussi une
idée de la liberté et que c'est aussi
une idée du bleu blanc rouge parce qu'en
fait le bas des oiseaux et rouge comme
une aube quelque chose qui commence
comme tout les revenus les révolutions
sont chargés d'espoir et puis le haut de
l'image c'est bleu parce que c'est le
ciel m'est donc ça fait bleu blanc rouge
c'est donc un dégradé très très simple
qui évoque l'espace sur le thème imposé
folle on avait eu d'autres idées les
oiseaux l'ont finalement emporté il ne
s'en plaint pas puisque pour lui
révolution égale liberté alors la
révolution c'est comme la liberté montre
le bout de son nez si vous voulez c'est
ça mon logo c'est ça mon image c'est que
je crois qu'on ne parlera jamais assez
de la liberté et que étrangement j'ai
fait presque en même temps une affiche
pour amnesty
ça représentait aussi une chose qui vole
je crois que oui au format grande
nostalgie c'est pas être un oiseau
c'est ce que tu aimes les images et
c'est de montrer c'est que montréal ça a
été effectivement d'être un oiseau et
moi ma grande nostalgie c'est de ne pas
être un cheval du tiercé sinon j'aurais
peut-être gagné cet après midi en tout
cas vous allez voir s'inscrire sur votre
écran
les résultats du tiercé et non pas les
rapports qu ils ne sont pas encore
parvenus en tout cas pour gagner il
fallait jouer
las le 3 et le 9
en revanche maintenant les prévisions
complètes de la météo avec josé pour
demain oui d'impôt demain nuage et plus
encore
daniel un couple qui fait vraiment
recette en ce moment effectivement en
provenance de l'espagne
une perturbation importante qui donnera
beaucoup de pluie du
languedoc-roussillon aux alpes y
comprise la côte d'azur et la corse avec
même parfois des orages encore ce
mauvais temps gagnera la franche-comté
et l'alsace partout ailleurs c'est à
dire sous les trois quarts du pays un
ciel capricieux où alterneront les
passages nuageux mais aussi les averses
et parfois quelques rayons de soleil
mais vraiment peu téméraire les
températures vont baisser légèrement la
vraie chute est prévue pour mardi il
fera 5 degrés à nancy 6 degrés de
limoges à grenoble et 14 à nice demain
lundi 23 novembre
n'oubliez pas clément merci josé tout de
suite après journal donc rendez vous
avec le film policier d'antenne 2 et
puis en fin de programme avec le
commissaire gassot pour les dernières
informations il aura l'occasion de vous
donner les résultats complets de
l'élection cantonale de marseille qui
est importante on a expliqué tout à
l'heure et puis demain matin un autre
rendez vous important dans le contexte
de la sphère air inter
monsieur edmond maire le secrétaire
général de la cfdt sera l'invité des 4
vérités vous pourrez en temps si vous
lever de bonne heure demain matin en
attendant je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée sur antenne 2 bonsoir
demain rendez-vous avec henri sannier je
compte sur vous la semaine prochaine
samedi et dimanche au revoir excellente
semaine